Egypt food price increased since 2021 20
to 30 current inflation rates over 12
food reserves enough to last only six
months since the start of the war in
Ukraine Egypt's food prices have become
unbearably expensive eighty percent of
the country's wheat comes from Russia
and Ukraine and so does a lot of its
cooking oil for a country whose people
rely heavily on bread as a staple food
having only four months of wheat
reserves left with no promises of being
able to import more is playing with fate
to say the least and what the average
salary in Egypt just around 500 a month
major price increases like these are
setting the country up for a crisis
Tunisia food price increases 2021 34
current inflation rate seven percent
food reserves none zero across Tunisia
shops are running out of food to sell to
angry customers
subsidized flour oil and rice have all
run outs nearly half of tunisia's wheat
Imports came from Ukraine and with the
Warren full swing and farming out of
halt tunisia's leaders fear the food
shortages will spark another Arab Spring
which was a series of anti-government
protests uprisings and arms rebellions
across much of the Arab world in the
early 2010s
Pakistan food price increased since 2021
over 30 percent current inflation rates
13 food reserves unknown the government
refuses to make the numbers public first
it was the Locust swarms then covid-19
stopped trade and now the war in Ukraine
is the last nail in Pakistan's food and
security coffin with wheat for me at
least 60 of the average pakistanis diets
a drop in Imports our food reserves
could bring the country to its knees
Ethiopia food press increased since 2021
over 150 percent current inflation rates
over 33 food reserves none Ethiopia has
never had a steady food supply major
parts of Ethiopia have always been on
the edge of famine and the war in
Ukraine is not doing anything to promote
stability with a drought drying up
almost all of the country's domestic
farming Ethiopia has no choice but to
rely on Imports to keep his people alive
but unfortunately in 2022 prices may be
just too high for people to afford all
around the world food prices are
skyrocketing flour wheat rice and oil
the food so in the poorest countries in
the world rely on to survive have become
scarce unaffordable the global food
price index is at the highest it's ever
been and everyone is feeling the Crunch
and for good reason Ukraine was the
world's sixth largest exporter of wheat
in the world with a 10 share of the
markets but the key word there is was
you see food prices have gone up so high
that analysts believe were on the brink
of the next Global food crisis luckily
for countries like the us we have an
easy 30 to 40 percent of our annual
calories sitting in reserves waiting to
be used in an emergency if Ukraine
suddenly stops exporting wheat like it
did we could also survive for at least
another 5 months without triggering mass
chaos other countries like Ethiopia and
Tunisia don't have that luxury most of
these countries rely on importing food
on loans to keep their people alive and
with Ukraine just being a little too
busy trying not to be destroyed to be
worried about this year's Harvest is
leaving a lot of opportunity for Mass
starvation or for someone to step in to
save all these poor countries from
famine and because America only has five
months of reserves for just Americans
it's not going to be America that saves
the day turns out there's one country
that's been stocking up food reserves
for years and this country is in the
perfect position to use those food
reserves as a geopolitical tool a
negotiation tool of sorts to dangle food
in the faces of starving populations so
they comply with this country's every
beck and call
in that country is China
[Music]
one of the simplest ways to save money
is by canceling subscriptions you no
longer need but if you're like me you
literally have too many subscriptions to
keep track of that is where true bill
comes in true bill is an all-in-one
personal finance app that I love using
and one of my favorite features is their
subscription tracker you just link up
your bank account and trouba will then
analyze and list out all these
subscriptions you have and how much
they're costing you you can even cancel
the ones you don't need right inside
truebill without ever leaving the app it
has saved me a ton of time and money
true bill has saved there over 2 million
users more than 100 million dollars and
Counting and another one of my favorite
features is that they'll negotiate to
lower your bills for you you select the
bill you want to lower enter some
information about yourself like your
address and that's it true bill can
negotiate your bill down on your behalf
truebill has an 85 success rate in
lowering bills if they're successful you
get to choose how much of those savings
you pay to true bill for their service I
usually choose 50 of whatever they save
me true bill is loaded with so many
other valuable features that I'm proud
to promote and all you have to do to get
started is pause the video and go to
truebell.com Jake with the link below
that's truebill.com Jake with the link
below so they know I sent you thanks to
true bill for sponsoring this video
[Music]
Ukraine and Russia are some of the
world's biggest food exporters together
they're responsible for nearly a third
of the worst wheat from which things
like flour is made and they're also
responsible for almost 20 percent of the
world's corn production and over half of
the world's sunflower oil and total 12
of the world's calories comes from
Ukraine or Russia but that's where the
biggest problem comes in you see
countries like the US and Canada are
pretty self-sufficient when it comes to
food production we all have our own corn
and wheat Farms so we don't really need
to import stuff from Ukraine or Russia
and Europe While most European countries
are wealthy enough to manage an increase
in food prices for most of us a loaf of
bread going from two dollars to 2.40
isn't really a big deal but for
countries like Ethiopia where most
people are only earning 35 to 40 dollars
a month a 20 to 30 price increase is a
nightmare and most of Ukraine's and
Russia's food exports used to go to
Regions like these in the Middle Eastern
Africa these countries governments would
make deals for Russia and Ukraine to
subsidize food or take loans out to keep
their people fed it wasn't an ideal
situation wishing but at least they
weren't starving but then the war came
along
and suddenly all of that flew out the
window
[Music]
Russia invades Ukraine the world
sanctions Russia and all that wheat and
corn they were exporting before yeah
that stuff is not going anywhere anymore
but here's the real kicker Russia is
also a major exporter of fertilizer so
even if countries wanted to avoid
starvation by planting their own food
there's now a shortage of fertilizer too
leading to fertilizer also skyrocketing
in price one farmer in Kenya has pretty
much given up on farming entirely for a
year she had been growing vegetables to
keep her family alive and to make money
on the side but now with all the
sanctions blocking Russia from exporting
fertilizer it will cost five times more
to fertilize her entire form than before
even if she could find fertilizer to buy
she would be losing money instead of
making it in this sense Russian
sanctions have backfired dramatically
now let's talk about Ukraine this is
their time for Farmers to be out there
planting corn right now right now this
is their time and they're not
why because farmers are soldiers first
it's kind of hard to focus on keeping
farmers happy with their jobs when your
country is at War so obviously food
production in Ukraine isn't anywhere
near where it was before the war do you
think that people understand how
important Ukraine is for feeding the
world
[Music]
now they do understand he says they may
not have before but now they get it
the same thing goes for exports since
most of Ukraine's food is shipped
through the Black Sea which currently is
a conflict Zone most of the ships are
stuck at Port with nowhere to go
odessa's Port is closed which has cut
off one of the world's largest exporters
of food Ukraine the size of Texas is
number four in corn and wheat number one
in sunflower oil
David Beasley told us half the wheat the
world food program needs worldwide is
stuck in Ukraine and things aren't
getting better anytime soon almost every
country around the world is worried
about wearing out food even with half a
Year's reserves is no guarantee that the
war won't go on much longer than that
leaving millions of people at risk of
starvation even in America food prices
are going up
all around the world countries are
trying to hoard food for themselves but
in all this chaos and fear one country
has seen an opportunity like never
before a chance to expand its reach
power and influence a chance to take
control of governments and Nations while
pretending it's only there to help that
country none other than China
foreign
[Music]
outlier for years China has been
stockpiling food and at this point china
has 150 percent of their annual
consumption of food in storage while
everyone else was occupied with the
crisis of the day China had been
secretly creating massive stockpiles of
food for years right now if the world
stopped producing any food China could
survive for one and a half years on the
food they have in storage and yet the us
only has enough reserves for not even
half of a year with a population four
times smaller than China and when the
war in Ukraine hits China didn't slow
down his food collection they bought up
half of the Lord's grains like wheat
which means they're also responsible for
pushing out food prices for everyone
else that means China is in the perfect
position for some food diplomacy
[Music]
foreign
for years the global power Dynamic has
maintained a very sensitive balance
between the world's superpowers every
chance they got China Russia and America
will try to tip the balance in their
favor and the war in Ukraine was no
exception you see for decades many
African South American and South Asian
countries have struggled to keep their
people fed educated and healthy without
outside help most of these countries are
rich in natural resources like gold oil
and other metals but they don't really
have the money or infrastructure to mine
or process any of these resources so
they agreed to trade with countries like
Russia China and the US you give us
money food security and medical
equipment and your companies get to come
in and Vine for gold or oil or maybe
even choose our next president if you're
lucky but here's the problem America has
almost always had the upper hand when it
comes to these trades no matter how much
money China and Russia throw out these
countries America's influence has always
had the upper hand until it comes to
food you see without food these African
Asian and South American countries are
at risk of chaos everyone knows what
happens when people can't buy food or is
too expensive to afford so when the time
inevitably comes China will probably
come in and offer them something no
other country can food America only has
enough food reserves to keep itself
going but China China has enough to use
as leverage against all the countries
that's interested in the deal you let us
take your natural resources you let us
influence your government UB Pro China
and anti-west and in exchange we'll give
you all the food you need no protest no
revolutions over the people without
having enough to eat you get to keep
your money your power your position and
we get to suck your country dry thanks
to the war in Ukraine China has been
given the opportunity of a lifetime to
shift the balance of power in some of
the most resource-rich countries in the
world
what's up guys hope you guys enjoyed the
video and if you're new here my name is
Jake and we make documentaries just like
this one every single week on money
power and crime multiple times a week
for free so if you enjoyed this one make
sure to click that subscribe button and
if you want longer ones that are too
controversial to post publicly click
that join button below I'm actually
working on one right now that is
definitely gonna get demonetized if I
post it publicly so you're not going to
want to miss it and if you join and you
don't think it's worth it there's a
refund policy so you can just email me
and I will read for you the money you
can follow me on Instagram at jtrend.io
that's going to wrap it up thank you so
much for watching stay dangerous out
there and I will see you guys in the
next one
foreign